heute läuft der vierte verhandlungstag
im prozess gegen stefan bei alledem
halle attentäter es kommen immer mehr
details ans licht offenbar wollte sich
seine mutter umbringen
sie hat einen abschiedsbrief
hinterlassen und genau dieser
abschiedsbriefe legt uns exklusiv vor
darüber möchte ich jetzt mitte bild
chefreporter maximilian kieffer sprechen
maximilian was weiß man über die mutter
claudia ballett genau also was wir
wissen und wussten ist dass der
attentäter eigentlich bis zum morgen
seiner tat im kinderzimmer bei seiner
mutter geschlafen hat und gelebt hat von
dort ist er aufgebrochen von dort hat er
den blutigen anschlag geplant und dann
auch durchgeführt und im unmittelbar
nach dem anschlag sind kollegen von
spiegel tv dort hingefahren und haben
die mutter gefragt haben die mutter
gefragt was hat ihr sohn gegen juden
warum tut er so was sie hat dann damals
geantwortet er hat nichts gegen juden in
dem sinne
er hat etwas gegen die leute die hinter
der finanziellen macht stehen wer hat
das nicht also sie ja da schon eine
rechte verschwörungstheorie von sich
gegeben über das angebliche jüdische
finanzkapital und wenn man dann noch
bedenkt dass die frau grundschullehrerin
ist und kinder unterrichtet hat kann
eigentlich nur schlecht werden und was
offenbar sie jetzt in ihrem brief den
hinterlassen hat genau
kurz danach sind dann bka-beamte in die
wohnung rein haben festgestellt dass die
frau offenbar tabletten genommen hat
eine flasche wein getrunken hat und
einen brief geschrieben hat sechs seiten
an ihre tochter geschrieben und in
diesem brief schreibt sie also über
ihren sohn und schreibt dort dieser
staat hat mich und stephan so im stich
gelassen und weiter schreibt sie er hat
eine gute seele sie haben ihn mir
zerstört vergisst das nie sie sind
gefährlich und natürlich fragt man sich
wenn meint sie mit sie und kurz danach
für die lehrerinnen das dann auch aus
indem sie eine verbindung zu juden
herstellt und schreibt sie fühlen dass
die juden freie hand hatten er hat sein
leben gegeben für die wahrheit für euch
er wollte nicht dass wir leiden er
wollte nur eins die wahrheit er hat
nichts geschaffen
sie schreibt dann noch mehrfach von der
selbstgemachten prophezeiung von den
juden die lügen und was sie dort
eigentlich darstellt probiert zu
erklären ist da ist ihr sohn jüdische
mächte haben ihr diesen sohn kaputt
gemacht er wollte nur eine wahrheit
aufdecken und das sozusagen ist
verhindert worden das sind verrückte
antisemitische theorien anders kann man
das nicht kann man das nicht
zusammenfassen ja das sind ja wirklich
krasse zeilen die man da liest wir
bewerten denn die ermittler diesen
abschiedsbrief genau uns liegt zu dem
brief eben auch das ja die die die
analyse des bka es vor und auch das will
ich einmal vorlesen
der leitende kriminalkommissare des bks
schreibt dort auffallend ist dass ihre
äußerungen zum judentum nicht auf
bestimmte person fokussiert sind sondern
auf das judentum im ganzen diese art der
argumentation entspricht
verschwörungstheorie tischen aussagen
gegen das judentum
sie hat dann auch judensterne auf den
brief gekritzelt hat die durchgestrichen
also da zeigt sich ganz klar bei dieser
frau ist etwas im kopf nicht in ordnung
und da ist ein ideologisches fundament
was womöglich gar nicht so weit entfernt
ist von dem ihres sohnes